mehr schwierig sagen weil die Eltern
davon zu überzeugen dass das auch
wirklich sichere Sport was hast häufig
gewesen sehr sicher wir sind sicherer
wie Autofahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlichst österreichischen Bundesheers
heute zu Gast beim sportreport koperal
Sebastian Graser herzlich willkommen
hallo christlich Fallschirmspringer
Weltmeister bei der Heim
Militärweltmeisterschaft im Ziel
springen er hat sich gratulation zu dem
Erfolg ist ja nicht so lange her
wie war das für dich bei der
heimweltmeisterschaft Weltmeister zu
werden es war wirklich unglaubliches
Gefühl es ist da richtig große Last von
Europa
was muss ich jetzt ähm wir hätten
eigentlich die Militär WM des Jahr davor
gehabt auf heimischen bodenner und da
wäre eine Junior gewesen
und dass das dann in der allgemeinen
Klasse das Jahr darauf funktioniert hat
ist natürlich aber Wahnsinn vor
verheimlichen Publikum von meiner
Freundin von meiner Familie Oliver da
ist war Erlösung pur und volle Freude
das
merkt man immer noch an im Ziel springen
hast du diesen Weltmeistertitel
geschafft das kann man sich unterm Ziel
springen falls man jetzt im
Fallschirmsprung Sport nicht so
nah ist das kann sich darunter
vorstellen genau Zielspringen ist
ähnlich wie Tatsache einmal wir
probieren den Mittelpunkt zu treffen
oder zielgenau was zu treffen aber wir
haben am Boden eine Scheibe liegen die
hat ein Radius von 16 cm in der Mitte
befindet sich ein kleiner Punkt mit
einem mit einem Durchmesser von 2 cm
sprich ungefähr eine 10 Cent Münze und
wir versuchen acht Mal hintereinander
dieses Ziel zu treffen je näher mir an
den Punkt dran sind desto weniger Punkte
Krieger und ja für Mittelpunkt wenn man
0 Zentimeter jeder Zentimeter Abweichung
ist ein Punkt mehr und mehr noch acht
Durchgängen die wenigsten Punkte hat
gewinnt das ganze genau aus welcher Höhe
springen das 1.000 Meter über Grund ab
eben kaum frei es geht rein um die um
die Ziellandung
aber das heißt du musst das 1000 Meter
Höhe dieses Ziel sehen wissen wann du
abspringst und dann auch noch hin
fliegen können wie macht man das es hat
halt mehrere Einflussfaktoren wir müssen
zuerst mal schauen wie Wind geht oben
dass man es nicht zu früh rausspringt zu
spät rausbringt dass man halt wirklich
das Ziel dann zum Schluss treffen kann
dann hat man gewisse Lande Einteilung
wir landen immer gegen den Wind weil es
weil es dadurch langsamer wird und dann
ist es einfach gleich wie bei jedem
Sport jahrelanges Training und wirklich
viel viel Training aber es dauert
Minimum einmal 500 Sprünge bis man
konstant wir haben Matte am Boden liegen
die hat ein Radius von ungefähr 200
Meter ist 500 Sprünge ca bis man die
halbwegs konstant trifft das passiert
immer nur dass man stecken oder irgendwo
unten aber es wird immer die Regel sein
und dann da als wieder 500 springe sage
mal konstant auf der Scheibe ist über 16
cm hat
und dann wäre es halt schwierig dass man
schaut dass man Konstanz den Klang gegen
Punkt in der Mitte trifft und
jahrelanges Training und für Training
was was zählt mit mit tatsächlich
irgendwie berühren oder darfst du nicht
den Bereich außerhalb berühren was dir
dann genauer als auf schreibt
grundsätzlich immer der erste
Bodenkontakt das heißt wenn jetzt ein
relativ flacher einer kommen und
blöderweise zuerst mit den Hintern die
Matte berühre zu dieser erste Punkt
vorteilhaft ist dass man mit der Ferse
landet wir haben im Prinzip ein kleinen
Stöckelschuh sorgen immer so wir haben
so einen kleinen Sporen hinten auf der
Ferse vom Schuh mit dem man eben genau
probieren diesen gelben Punkt zu treffen
das heißt das zählt dann was das nicht
wo Du dann liegen geblieben hast du
immer grundsätzlich der erste
Bodenkontakt aber jetzt erst mit der
Hand aufkommen oder mit irgendwas anders
waren jetzt z.B mit den linken Fuß
zuerst aufkommen mit dem rechten Fuß
aber steigen will auf die Scheibe dann
zählt mein linker Fußsohle kriegt die
Folgen 16 Punkte das heißt man hat einen
Topf gehabt aber wenn man am Schluss
dann falsch
ganz passt und der Link geht zuerst auf
kommt kriegst du Avon der rechte
richtige Nuller drinnen war die 16
Punkte und 16 Punkte ist Totschlag also
dann fast schon wirklich Dart spielen
halt mit dem mit dem Schluss wenn du
sagst man braucht 500 die Matte trifft
kann ich mir vorstellen dass die ersten
500 Sprünge eher schmerzhafter sind am
Boden oder
schmerzhaft ist doch gar nichts
man kann trotzdem sanft natürlich kann
man den Schirm nicht so landen wie man
auf die Matte kommt weil wir probieren
im Prinzip ungefähr zwei Meter über dem
Zielpunkt zu sein und dann grad
abzusteigen das geht auf dem normalen
Boden nicht weil sonst du da so langsam
noch ans Brüste die Fersen oder sonst
irgendwas da musst du dann anders landen
wenn du nicht auf die Matte kommst genau
oder Lande Rolle machen zum
sicherheitslanden das heißt doch da gibt
es Szenarien umso reagieren wenn man
nicht trifft was auch immer wieder
vorkommt jetzt hast du deine
Weltmeistertitel mit nur 3 cm Abweichung
geschafft was ich jetzt verstehe aus 8
Sprüngen 3 cm heißt im Endeffekt dass
fast alle Sprünge perfekt dran oder
beinahe ich habe angefangen mit einem
Zentimeter glaube ich und dann an zwei
Zentimeter oder umgekehrt bin immer
sicher und dann habe ich sechs mein
Serien Urlaub gemacht also sechs mein
Serie wirklich das den Mittelpunkt rufen
was er gleichzeitig österreichische
Rekord ist es war recht lustig weil wir
sind gemeinsam mit die deutschen
einstiegen und noch einen zweiten Sprung
habe von der deutschen gesagt ob jetzt
nur noch und dass man dann wirklich bis
zum Schluss aufgegangen ist ist
unglaublich wirklich wahnsinn das ist so
eine Leistung etwas was man alle paar
Jahre vielleicht irgendwie schafft oder
kann man das dann wirklich konstant
abrufen und dann immer mit 3 cm
absolute beste Leistung gewesen mein
Bester Bewerber waren 15 cm diese Person
davor habe es geschafft dass ich
halbwegs konstant um an Zentimeter
Schnitt springt
und 3 cm war wirklich absolute Serie bis
20 Jahre und das war's doppelte also
war für mich Neuland es gibt Springer
die schaffen das konstanter sage immer
da gibt es den Stefan Wiesner von der
Deutschen zum Beispiel die haben ganz
andere Trainingsmöglichkeiten wie wir
der hat bei der WM 2018 in Ungarn hat
der 70er also der der ist einer der
einzigen springende was so Leistungen
wirklich konstante über Jahre springen
kann ja was müsstest du tun um auch
dieses Niveau zu erreichen ich nehme an
dass du das als Ziel gesetzt hast
natürlich ist das mein großes Ziel bei
uns ist es wirklich einfach springen
springen springen bringen weil wir haben
natürlich ein Simulator wo man jetzt die
letzten zwei Meter über Boden simulieren
wo man jetzt wirklich nur auf die
steigen konzentrieren auf das dass er
den 0,5
aber dann sind es einfach so viel
verschiedene Wetterbedingungen du kannst
dir einfach nicht auf alles einstellen
du bist noch nicht ausgesprungen und da
hast du einfach in die Luft kommen in
die Luft kommen und
das heißt schlimmer sagt er möchte ein
paar Zehnter schneller werden dann muss
seine bestimmte Anzahl an Kilometer
schaffen oder einen Umfang bei euch ist
es dann der sprungumfang damit man eben
die Routine hat und diese Null da
Leistungen so schaffen kann genau sehr
sehr spannend da habe ich wieder was
neues gelernt was macht für dich denn
Reiz am Zielspringen aus wie gibt's ganz
viel Film ich bin im Herzen zu springen
und wir machen andere Disziplinen an
aber mehr Herz schlägt eigentlich nur
fürs zuspringen der Perfektionismus in
dem Sport weil es eigentlich wirklich
Perfektionismus so oft hintereinander
den Nullen und das ist eigentlich fast
der unmöglich ist zudem dass man hat und
deswegen gibt es einfach immer neige
welche müssen setzen kann welche Wege
und welche Ziele weil man eigentlich
dass man wirklich den Perfektionismus
erreicht den gibt es man kann nicht sein
ganzes Leben Null durchbringen gleich
wieder da spielen ganze ganzes Leben
immer 100 daily schafft das ist einfach
der Reiz dran das unendliches Limit gibt
eigentlich du hast andere Disziplinen
auch noch angesprochen und ich glaube
wir haben im Hintergrund genau ein Bild
vom formationsspringen oder wie es wie
es genannt wird was muss man in diesen
springarten mitnehmen alles Formation
springen ist ihm im Vergleich zum zu
springen komplett der andere Disziplin
beim Skispringen geht's rein um die um
die Schirm vor dem Prinzip dann
Formation springen jetzt rein und freien
Folge wie man hinten auf dem Bild
schickt ist es am Mannschaft Disziplin
also immer vier Leute plus ein
Kameramann im im freien Fall gibt
genauso das die interdisziplin das
damals nur zu viel plus Ersatzmann
und man kann sich das ein bisschen wie
danzen vorstellen man hat eine gewisse
Kühe vorgeben von Formationen die was
man sie merken muss und die was man
fliegen muss und da ist halt extrem
wichtig da Rhythmus die Kommunikation
obwohl es nicht kommunizieren kannst im
freien Fall weil es mir ist nicht immer
alle Griffe gleichzeitig passen und alle
gleichzeitig gelöst werden sonst sollte
das Punkt aber das klingt als wäre seine
andere Sportart mit der Gemeinsamkeit
dass man halt runterfällt genau so kann
man das Lautsprecher es ist das gleiche
ist dass mir irgendwann am Fallschirm
hängt und dass mir irgendwann ein
Flugzeug verlost das was eigentlich
fliegt aber grundsätzlich ist äh
grundverschiedene Disziplin wer ist wie
Rückenschwimmen es ist Schwimmen beides
aber das andere ist doch anders
besonderes macht dann die körperlichen
Voraussetzungen anders trainieren muss
physisch wichtig grundsätzlich ist
überall wichtig die die herum Spannung
zu haben weil wenn du Docker Spannung
hast funktioniert das alles nicht beim
Skispringen sage jetzt mehr Koordination
wichtig jetzt sind und Schnelligkeit und
Reaktionsfähigkeit es ist schon springen
angegeben aber da musstet mehr auf dem
Rücken schauen es ist jetzt nicht so
schnell zum reagieren wie im Skispringen
aber körperliche Anforderungen
sportlich sein Grundlagen aus da haben
koordinative Fähigkeiten es ist sehr
vielseitig so gemacht wie bist du zum
Fallschirmspringen gekommen ja ich bin
über ein Skisport eigentlich erkunden
ich bin ja in der Schladming gewesen und
mein großes Ziel wenn ich bin
jahrelanger Dominik waren einfach nur
Buchstaben und ich bin jetzt nicht der
größte und bin dann mit 14 Jahren 40
Kilo
Kopfkino haben unter 15.net und fein von
meinem Vater der Ecke Michael der macht
eben die Kombination Fallschirmspringen
und Skifahren da gibt's im Winter die
Disziplin da fahren wir ganz normal
Riesentorlauf und dann zu springen und
das wird wie in der Nordischen
Kombination zusammen Zeit und der
nächste okay
du kannst dann Sport machen und du
darfst nicht immer Skifahren wieso nicht
und wir zu mir kommen ist heute den
Unterschied zwischen Paragleiten und und
eigentlich und kurz bevor der Infoabend
dann
2012 war hat mein Papa gesagt
keine Ahnung gehen
und seitdem hat mir eigentlich immer
loslassen und jetzt bin ich mit Herz und
Leidenschaft dabei hat es keine Angst
vor dem ersten Sprung
meine erste Sprung war eigentlich ja
gleichzeitig mein erster Flug in einem
Flugzeug und davor bin ich geflogen
meine Eltern haben mir um zwar noch
dafür abgeholt und dann sagen wir
aufgefahren danach suchen zu meinem
ersten Fallschirmsprung und bin
eigentlich ja recht ruhiger Mensch jetzt
sind kack quasselt oder sonst irgendwas
und ich habe die anderthalb Stunden
aufgeklärt und nervös Ende nie dann
eigentlich wie ein Flieger gesessen bin
und wie das Signal Kommunist in die Tür
ist irgendwie die ganze Nervosität
verflogen gewesen da ist irgendwie
einfach nur funktioniert das machen was
da kommt dann geht das und ja dann bin
ich draußen gewesen und dann realisiert
das eigentlich erst drei vier fünf
Sprünge was du da eigentlich komplett
Iris gemacht hast also am fliegenden
Flugzeug auszuspringen bist du
echt sehr sehr cool und hat mein Leben
sehr geprägt wie war das Gefühl dass du
zum ersten Mal gelandet bist wie gesagt
da habe ich das ganze noch nicht
realisiert das ist so richtig erst drei
vier Sprünge später kommen denkst
Wahnsinn unglaublich also richtig
richtig cool aber komplett ihre aber ja
alles
gut so würde ich sagen bis dann besser
Skifahrer dann besser oder falsch im
Springer haben mittlerweile
garantiert ja welche Fähigkeiten die du
im Skifahren gelernt hast helfen dir
jetzt beim Fallschirmspringen
unglaublich viel unglaublich viel
einfach durch die ganze schulische
Ausbildung durch die Hauptschule die
ganzen kardinativen Fähigkeiten merke
einfach was du ihm viele Leute da
gelernt hast bringen da enorm viel weil
es einfach alles was du im Kino ist
heute im Schulleiter lernst bringt dir
irgendwas und
durch das dass mir da sehr koordinativ
ausbildet worden sind ist es
super gewesen eigentlich gibt nichts
besseres als als vorspurter zum falschen
springen sage die Skifahrt wie viele
Sprünge hast du jetzt mittlerweile kann
es nicht genau sagen aber eine ganz drei
tausend wird das irgendwo mitgeschrieben
oder hat jeder seine eigene
Dokumentation
durchführen es ist ja dann für gewisse
Lizenzen musst du Sprung noch weiß
vorlegen können jetzt Tante Master
werden würde Sprunglehrer muss ich
gewisse Stunden Freizeit vor allem
Kindern und für das ist das schon sehr
wichtig das ist nicht mit Lücken
dokumentiert sondern wirklich lückenlos
dokumentiert ist
es ist ja auch kann ich mir gut
vorstellen dass man wenn man dann
darunter springt und Ziel einmal nicht
getroffen hat dass man analysieren
möchte was war gibt es Möglichkeiten es
gibt viele coole Videos von euch aber
dass man wirklich auf Videoanalyse macht
wo habe ich den Wind falsch eingeschätzt
wo habe ich vielleicht falsch gesteuert
gibt es da sehen möchte das
grundsätzlich viel mit dem
normalen Tablet schauen uns das dann
dann im Nachhinein an und da wird schon
analysiert ja da habe ich ein Fehler
gemacht du weit stark in der Bremsen da
später ausgegangen ich war von Anfang an
so da wird es schon noch in ein Prinzip
wieder Analyse gemacht und auf die
Technik schaut und verfeinert und da
muss natürlich auch jemand drüber
schauen das sind oftmals der Trainer die
natürlich selber auch jahrelang
gesprungen sind und natürlich auch
Experten aus dem Bundesheer falsche
springen ist der eine militärische
Schwerpunkt Sport hat
wo kann man dagegenseitig lernen ihr
Profi Springer und dann gibt's natürlich
die militärischen Springer wo sind die
Unterschiede kann man gegenseitig sich
unterstützen also grundsätzlich ist
jetzt das Sport springen und das
militärische springen großer Unterschied
weil wir sind wirklich nur da dass mir
den kleinen Punkt treffen dass mir so
viel Informationen machen wie möglich
und dass mir in Stil so schnell wie
möglich links Kreis sagt wir haben die
militärische Ausbildung machen müssen
sagt wir haben sechs grundkappensprung
machen mit Waffen Gepäck wir haben die
militärische freifallausbildung machen
müssen Waffe und Gebäck und daher
sorgeträume zwischen uns und und
Gewissen gewissen Soldaten
Zusammenarbeit wir sind wieder Neustadt
wo man sich gegenseitig hilft bei diese
freifallausbildung hilft uns das Militär
wie genau mache die Sprünge jetzt mit
dem Gepäck genauso können wir jetzt den
Song nochmal
militärspringen zu erklären wie Gummi am
besten in der relativ klare Zone eine
und da ist eigentlich da geht das ganze
Hand in Hand und das ist eigentlich
hervorragend weil so haben wir ein
Output fürs Militär aus Militär hat was
für uns und das ist eigentlich schon
sehr sehr cool kann man auch dann die
militärischen Ressourcen nutzen für euch
als profispringen genau wir haben im
Prinzip gewisses Kontingent und
Militärflieger was mir nutzen wir
schauen das mit zivile Flieger anmieten
wir schauen dass man das militärisch
machen und so geht das ganze bei uns
eigentlich Hand in Hand sie will das
Leben und und militärische Basis ja
gibt's die Möglichkeit Springer war dass
man nachher sagt ich möchte beim Herr
bleiben und werde Profi
militärischspringer nein diese
Möglichkeit gibt es bei uns nicht so
ganz natürlich gibt's die Möglichkeit
dass man irgendwie im Militär verankert
bleibt aber wir haben jetzt keine
langzeitverträge wir haben nur die die
militärperson auf Zeitverträge und ich
kann jetzt den Sportler bis zum bis zu
meiner Pension werden das das geht nicht
ganz aber du könntest danach als
Fallschirmspringer als Soldat im Einsatz
fürs
dabei ja die Möglichkeiten also von der
Fähigkeiten her würde es gehen ja
natürlich brauchst du dann wieder die
Zusatzausbildung für für die einzelnen
Einheiten ich kann jetzt einfach sagen
hey ich möchte Spezialeinheit Soldaten
da brauche genauso den ganz normaler
Grundkurse etc der bringt mir das jetzt
nichts dass sie falsch rum springen
kannst sage weil er einfach nicht mit
der Waffe umgehen kann aber ja
Möglichkeiten gibt sind es gibt ja genau
Wirklichkeit gibt was kannst du denn
vorstellen auf deiner falsche Springer
Tätigkeit der Kamera natürliche lange
genug machen aber was kann man für
zivile Leben dann mitnehmen ich habe
jetzt Studium gemacht ein Sportler
Eventmanagement das heißt es ist die
duale Ausbildung das Militär was was
extrem unglaublich ist dass man das
machen kann und ich möchte eigentlich
unbedingt in dem fallschirmsportart beim
Militär in irgendeiner Art und Weise
vertreten sein doch das dass sie mit
meinem Kommandanten recht gut versteht
kann man da in Zukunft der Kooperationen
machen mit gastle Aufträge wo man
unterstützen kann einfach dass der Sport
erhalten bleibt weil es einfach durch
eine sehr kleine Rennsportler die sage
jetzt einmal und und nicht die große
Förderung hat wie mache ich andere
Sportarten muss man sich einfach extrem
viel im gegenseitiger freundschaftlicher
Basis für und das möchte unbedingt
erhöhten bleiben so in Zukunft wie
würdest du neue junge Leute zum Sport
bekommen das ist ganz ganz schwierig
weil einfach das Schwierige ist
15-jährige die die sagen ja vielleicht
cool aber dann gibt es die Eltern na du
springst mir nicht aus dem Flieger leute
das ist mehr schwierig solche Eltern
davon zu überzeugen dass das auch
wirklich sichere Sport was hast du
wirklich gewesen sehr sicher wir sind
sicherer wie Autofahren aber da ist mehr
der schwierige Eltern zu überzeugen dass
das Kinder machen können oder machen
dürfen sage mal ist das Thema Sicherheit
so präsent unsere Sicherheit ist extrem
hoch sage jetzt mal wir haben extrem
viele Schutzfaktoren das eigentlich
nichts passieren kann und warum was
passiert dann ist es eigentlich die
Schuld des eigenen Springers weil man
vergessen hat was einzuschalten oder
sonst irgendwas oder die Wartungen nicht
durchgeführt hat aber von außen
betrachtet schaut das aus als warten wir
die komplett wahnsinnigen die was könnte
was lebensmüde aus dem Flieger zu Boden
springen aber eigentlich ja wir sind
immer gefährlichste ist die Anreise zum
Flugplatz und die Heimreise bitte
springen selber ist
3000 Sprünge eben noch nie ein Reserve
Fallschirm braucht weil ich immer
schnell Bock habe ich habe noch nie
Verletzung gehabt war noch nie in
irgendeiner Situation dass irgendwas
vorstellt passieren können und das noch
zehn Jahre Frage mein Skifahrer wie oft
dass sie in zehn Jahren Profisport
verletzt hat oder ein Schwimmer
nicht aufpassen
verstaucht ja okay das heißt sollte man
es doch vielleicht noch ein falsch
aber wir sind natürlich auch sehr
Ressourcen intensiv wenn du sagst ja ihr
habt bestimmte
Flugzeiten die nutzen kannst und und
bestimmte Ressourcen die nutzen kannst
gibt es eine Möglichkeit das Springen zu
simulieren ohne in die Luft zu gehen
richtig ja da gibt's zum Beispiel den
Windkanal in in Wien zum Beispiel da
kann man den freien Fall simulieren
natürlich ist es günstigste aber dass
man das ausprobieren kann für zwei drei
Minuten ein geht ist sich schon sehr
ähnlich natürlich hast du den coolen
Ausblick nicht
aber es ist es ist recht lässige
Simulation für das ganze was war dein
coolster Sprung den du bisher hattest
coolste Sprung war garantiert der bei
der Weltmeisterschaft mein letzter
Sprung in der achten Runde ich habe 3 cm
noch sieben Runden habe gewusst mit dem
ansah bin ich zumindestens zweiter mit
einem Nuller bin ich garantiert
Weltmeister und eigentlich war das
geplant dass dass man das nur am Abend
machen den Sprung und dann ist
schlechter Wetter kommen und dann haben
wir das verschieben müssen dann war noch
höllisch nervös wirklich das war der
grausame noch und dann am nächsten Tag
haben wir den Sprung gemacht und das war
eigentlich
wir sind muss man sagen beim falschen
springen wirklich wirklich große Familie
und da da steht einfach der komplette
sprungkreis der ganze Familie war da und
dann habe ich eigentlich nicht den
perfekten Anflug kumauber und es hält
diese Sirene auf dass sie den Urlaub
gemacht habe und das war
Wahnsinn warum glaube ich das Gefühl es
war echt der Traum und das würde schon
als mein coolsten Sprung eigentlich
bewerten weil das war gesagt natürlich
die Landschaft und das was man sieht die
Aussicht der was ist Dir ganz besonders
in Erinnerung geblieben aussichtsmäßig
es ist so viel unterschiedlich da gibt's
auf der anderen Seite springe mir recht
viel Niederlande was eigentlich
unglaublich ist äh mit mit dem Gremium
im Hintergrund
auf der anderen Seite Dubai wann es
direkt über der Palme abspringst ist
genauso Traum dann war meine Amerika
Wüste meilenweit nix kilometerweit gar
nichts was genauso lässig ist
das ist halt extrem cool weil es einfach
durch das auch vielseitig ist und man
sieht alles also aus 4000 Meter sechs
schon richtig richtig weit
aber ich mache die zwei Zentimeter Ziele
Scheibe dann nicht so gut ähm wo wird
jetzt der falsche Sprung Sport so
richtig intensiv gelebt gibt es
irgendwie eine Nationen oder einen Ort
wo man sagt das ist das Make-up dort
wird das einfach Vollgas gelebt das ist
jetzt ein abhängig von dem wie man sieht
wenn man sagt gar nicht springen und
rein Spaß dann sind es sicher
Sprungplätze wie eine Amerika als keine
Leute dann ist es keine Dubai das ist
halt mehr so das habe ich schon springen
aber wenn das wirklich intensiv auf auf
leistungssport ist sicher Deutschland da
die stärkste Disziplin weil einfach die
Förderung durch Militär unglaublich groß
ist die machen im Jahr um die 600 bis
1000 Sprünge fliegen zwar im Jahr nach
Amerika auf Trainingslager
die sind einfach jetzt und seit 2019
jedesmal Militär wird was da im gesamten
waren als die drei Disziplinen
kombiniert mit Skispringen Formation
springen und Zielspringen die Santos
sicher die stärksten haben vermutlich
hatte stärkte Gersten Ressourcen dazu
gleich wie überall sondern Ressourcen
einfach immer unglaublich wichtig aber
das sind sicher die stärksten aber
offensichtlich gibt es einen
Erkenntnisgewinn der auch militärische
sinnvoll ist weil sonst würden
wahrscheinlich nicht so viel in eine
Beziehung oder unbedingt es gibt auf
jeden Fall die sind da am Sprungplatz in
Deutschland haben die die den
hauptsprung Platz gemeinsam mit der mit
der Ausbildungsstätte für die für die
forschungsspringer und gleich wie bei
uns geht es total in Hand äh gibt's
immer was weiter und genau und
funktioniert offensichtlich sehr gut
kommen wir zum Abschluss noch zwei paar
Fragen als Kind wollte ich Hermann schon
gesagt oder was solltest du denn noch so
als Kind Weltmeister werden und das
Zuhörer erreicht das ist das ist sicher
große
Punkte nicht gerne und vor allem im
Heimatland war Traum jetzt Weltmeister
werden ist er bei euch so dass ihr öfter
Weltmeister werden kann setzt man sich
da neue Ziele und sagt einmal
Weltmeister schön aber insgesamt zehn
Mal über die ganze Karriere wird auch
schön oder man muss jetzt sagen ich bin
schon immer irgendwas
sicherlich nicht den gleicher Ergebnis
wieder bringen ich möchte jetzt an die
Leistung anknüpfen und nicht schauen
dass jetzt wieder ein Rückschritt macht
sondern einfach die Leistung festhalten
und natürlich noch eines genauso schnell
und doppelter wird man einfach sehr
schön
wie würdest du den Stellenwert
Weltmeisterschaft und Welt Games noch
einschätzen man muss sitzen sagen bei
uns dann einfach die Weltmeisterschaften
durch das dass mir alle bei Militär sind
ob wir sind World Games oder wird
Meisterschaften ist Sand überall die
gleichen sportlerfahrer dabei ist es
macht jetzt da kein Unterschied oder
oder Weltmeisterschaften und somit hast
für mich eigentlich ziemlich den
gleichen Stellenwert natürlich auch das
normale
Games aber grundsätzlich hat den ist für
unsere Weltmeisterschaft
sehr viel hören von dir da bin ich mir
sicher ohne Spaß bin ich
verloren ja kennst meine Freundin fragen
wann die an doch kein Sport machen und
dann und dann ist nicht zum aushalten
was würdest du sagen ist deine stärkste
Eigenschaft
ah sehr zielstrebig sein und waren jetzt
über Augen gehabt dann dann investiert
das ist erreichen kann also sozusagen
seine Eigenschaft eine
Charaktereigenschaft oder eine
Eigenschaft die du hast die dich eher
blockiert
viel mit mir reden was was sicher nicht
Vorteil auf den jeder Situation ist
ja
dann unnützes Talent unnützes Talent
schwierige Frage wird es immer noch nie
gemacht
[Musik]
ich bin koordinativ sehr stark das ist
doch jetzt das hat man sehr viel braucht
in dem Sport
koordinative Stärke sicher an meiner
stärksten Talente was würdest du sagen
wer doch dein großer Traum
ja der große Traum ist sicherer
Mannschaft zu werden das ist das was was
eigentlich glaube ich noch mehr über
allem steht gemeinsam mit dem Team lass
mich nicht wird was damit alles und
gewinnen weil wenn
das ist glaube ich schon am erlässig wo
man dann gemeinsam mit seine vier
basisste was man da unterwegs ist dann
trainiert da oben steht und gemeinsam
feiern konnte das ist das ist glaube ich
richtig richtig cool auf den Tag der
Erfüllung des Tages freuen uns
herzlichen Dank Sebastian alles Gute
vielen Dank danke euch dabei sein beim
Sport reparat wir freuen uns schon aufs
nächste Mal bis dann
[Applaus]